l'un gauthier cofondateur du collectif
des parties civiles pour le rwanda
bonsoir alain gautier merci d'être avec
nous ce rapport du clair comment lé
accueillez-vous un pas en avant vers une
compréhension commune de ce qui s'est
passé comme le dit le président mambé
oui probablement
un pas en avant c'est un rapport qui est
volumineux qui reconnaît une
responsabilité écrasante des
responsables politiques de 1994 en
particulier françois mitterrand et tout
son entourage
mais nous nous continuons à dire que ça
ne suffit pas de reconnaître
responsabilités pour nous depuis
toujours nous avons dit que il y avait
complicité
complicité de génocide complicité ne
veut pas dire que la france a voulu le
génocide
mais le gouvernement français 2,94 a
soutenu le président habyalimana et
ensuite à soutenu le gouvernement
intérimaire qui a commis le génocide
donc nous continuons à parler de
complicité de génocide
clairement comment réagissent les
parties civiles que voudrait-elle
justement des excuses alors oui bien sûr
des excuses si le président macron se
rend au rwanda
bien évidemment nous attendons des
paroles très fortes
une véritable reconnaissance de de ce
que ce rôle a été qui a été désastreux
non seulement pour l'image de la france
mais aussi pour toutes les victimes
sur le plan de la justice nous attendons
surtout que des moyens beaucoup plus
importants soit donnée au pôle crimes
contre l'humanité pour que les personnes
qui sont soupçonnées d'avoir participé
au génocide des tutsi et qui vivent en
france et bien puisse être déférée
devant la justice en 27 ans il n'y a eu
quand même que trois personnes jugées et
condamnées et bien évidemment on ne peut
pas se satisfaire de ce bilan
nous avons déposé au collectif des
parties civiles plus d'une trentaine de
plats
quatre personnes sont encore déferré
devant la cour d'assises mais dans
combien de temps vont elles être jugé
cette lenteur de la justice
véritablement nous désespère et
désespère les les rescapés du génocide
c'est insupportable comment vous
expliquer justement les conclusions de
ce rapport qu'il parle de responsabilité
l'eau n'est pas de complicité c'est pour
vous une erreur d'appréciation une forme
de manque d'indépendance alors je
n'irais pas jusqu'à dire une un manque
d'indépendance en ce monsieur duclair a
toujours dit qu'il travaillait
précisément en toute indépendance
mais je crois que c'est un rapport
d'historiens qui a voulu se cantonner
aux archives qui l'ont trouvée sans
vouloir aller jusqu'à prononcer le mot
de complicité je vous ai dit que pour
nous ce n'est pas ce n'est pas suffisant
sur le plan juridique nous continuons à
dire que il y a eu complicité
il faut quand même savoir que le ceto a
l'ambassade de france à kigali que le
gouvernement intérimaire a été formé et
dans ce gouvernement intérimaire
il n'y avait que des extrémistes hutus
donc il y à une compromission évidente
avec les tueurs
alors aujourd'hui à paris paris a
annoncé l'ouverture au grand public
d'importantes archives notamment celle
de l'ancien président socialiste
françois mitterrand au pouvoir à
l'époque génocide et outils vous en
attendez quelque chose je ne sais pas
peut précisément vous savez en fait nous
savons beaucoup de choses déjà nous ça
fait ça fait bientôt trente ans que on
travaille sur le génocide des tutsi avec
mon épouse on a toujours voyagé au
rwanda depuis depuis pratiquement 50 ans
donc nous connaissons bien la région
on va voir ce que ces archives la révèle
on est prêts on est prêt à prendre de
nouvelles révélations
mais je crois que l'essentiel est dit
maintenant c'est une
ouverte à aller beaucoup plus loin dans
dans l'histoire de ce génocide dans
l'enseignement j'ai entendu le le
ministre de l'éducation nationale par
les deux du génocide comme une matière
d'enseignement
c'est ce que nous nous faisons aussi
très régulièrement dans les lycées en
plus du travail de justice que nous
faisons pour les rescapés
clairement il ya encore de nombreuses
zones d'ombré qui résident dans cet
épisode tragique
oui il ya des zones d'ombré par exemple
rien n'est dit sur sur l'attentât qui a
coûté la vie au président habyalimana je
ne sais pas si les archives on disait on
disait davantage probablement pas oui il
y à t'il il y aura toujours des choses à
apprendre savez en est que le 27 ans
après le génocide donc il faut continuer
à travailler les historiens doivent
continuer leur travail mais nous ce qui
nous importe
et le temps presse parce que le temps
joue en faveur des bourreaux ce qui nous
importe c'est que les personnes qui sont
actuellement visé par des plaintes
puisse être jugé le rapport ne va pas
nous aider beaucoup simplement de deux
personnes que nous poursuivre en justice
sont évoqués dans ce rapport c'est
madame habyarimana qui vit
tranquillement dans son village à
courcouronnes dans l'essonne et l'ex
chef d'état major adjoint de l'armée le
colonel laurent sédogo gars qui lui vit
dans le nord
or ces deux dossiers n'avancent pas
véritablement et c'est ça qui nous
importe c'est que justice soit rendue
comment va faire la justice française
pour juger ne serait ce déjà que la
trentaine de personnes contre lesquelles
nous avons déposé des plaintes
je sais ça notre angoisse merci elle a
un gauthier cofondateur du collectif des
parties civiles pour le rwanda d'avoir
été avec nous